We are going to welcome now to the stage who I feel like with this is like a
Lakers game.
You guys are going to run down and like they got let but let's do it.
Maybe if we're going to do it that way in order.
Um,
of course.
Let's bring up first Frank Miller,
creator
commander of the Dark Knight returns.
We're going to go in a different order.
Tony Patrick who is just done Batman and the signal.
Okay.
Sean Murphy who is a just dropped Batman White Knight.
Frank Miller,
the creator of dark knight returns.
Huh?
Getting the current writer of Batman and James Chaney and the fourth,
the current writer of detective comics.
No,
no,
you're welcome.
Thank you for coming out.
We are super,
super excited.
So,
um,
I want to jump out and there's throw some questions out that are for all of you.
Um,
Batman is one of the most well known,
well loved characters in the world across literature and yet dark,
brooding,
tortured,
broken kick,
Sadik,
ridiculously wealthy,
um,
basically unrelatable in almost every aspect.
How do you account for this popularity of the character?
I thought he was a bundle of joy.
Right?
Maybe,
Hey,
look,
he's having a good time.
Maybe the Crook Siren,
but he's all right.
He ain't so gloomy.
Yeah.
He,
he'd come in,
he comes from a,
from a very dark beginning,
but,
but uh,
you don't keep doing something for that long and,
uh,
because you're depressed.
Okay.
So it's just me that keeps doing the depressing.
No,
you just keep doing what you're doing.
Uh,
I,
I'd say,
um,
what,
what I relate to is he sort of a machine for turning pain into hope.
Like,
Ooh,
he's a super power.
The one power he has the stand next to Batman and wonder woman is that his
parents were killed.
Like that's an odd superpower to have.
But what makes him powerful?
Is it the worst moment in his life?
He turns that moment into strength.
And I think a lot of people,
when they look at their lives,
they sort of come to realize that,
that the pain and the worst parts of you become like the greatest parts of you.
That becomes sort of what you rely on in the,
in the bad moments.
He's like,
I've been through something,
I've done something horrible or I've been through something horrible,
now I can handle the horrible,
it's coming at me.
Like Friedrich Nietzsche.
Yeah.
Like Frederick Nietzsche,
Ana.
Okay.
Batman's looked into the abyss and as we all have,
and this was afraid.
It's the one time that's happened.
Yeah.
Um,
and so that's all right.
I guess that's a take I had not seen on that.
Do you in terms of hold it all right.
Um,
all right.
I happy and hopeful Batman.
Um,
some of that seems to revolve around the family and each of you is taken,
um,
a different approach to giving Batman a family of sorts.
What,
how have you come at that?
What did,
what does a successful back family look like?
Um,
lots of,
lots of like pointy ears
and lots of Robin's bags and Robin
short shorts and I wasn't,
I can I even cut the Antony infant Tino cupboard that I've always wanted to see
that never existed was,
was to have Batman on the bat phone in the bat cave.
I'm sitting next to the Batmobile,
um,
talking onto the bat phone saying,
Oh,
commissioner,
this is a tough job.
This may cost me six,
seven robins.
Huh?
Once they started killing one,
then they killed another effort.
Here.
It's open season.
We don't even bother with the 900 number anymore.
Yes.
Oh God.
I mean,
I think one of the,
one of the things about that like,
cause family is built into the entire concept of Batman,
uh,
Bruce lost family.
And that is,
that's the sort of,
that is the founding trauma that led him on this path.
So that story ultimately goes to building family.
That's what he,
that that's really the only way out of,
of where of where he started.
And,
uh,
and it's,
you know,
it's everything that you,
that you lose when you experience that kind of trauma.
He can find,
he can't find through himself necessarily any more,
but he can find it through these other people,
these other sources of light around him.
Um,
and that's the,
I mean,
that's been sort of one of the driving principles.
Uh,
my detective comics run is sort of a Batman teen book with a lot of the,
you know,
now there are a million like people who have been sidekicks to Batman at
different points.
And I just brought up a bunch of my favorites and stuck them in one book.
Uh,
but this one like it,
it allows each one sort of taps into a different core aspect of Bruce r that
allows him to kind of a approach the,
the light,
uh,
again,
and that's why you get the incredible bright colored costumes and all of that
compared to the blacks and grays.
Um,
but
interesting.
All right.
Um,
well on that note,
so we have now the,
the robins are the new proteges keep increasing.
Um,
we have the signal a lot of a lot of people with guns up there.
Yeah.
Well that also need a good soccer.
Robin's brightly colored Robinson 20 of them.
Yeah.
I mean the Batmobile is permanently parked outside the going to the orphanage.
I mean,
it's
kids love cars.
It's true.
Getting back to the newest protege.
So we have the signal who is joining this pedigree of,
of sort of bat like heroes,
cannon fodder.
Um,
we hope not.
And I use three,
right.
Give him a little time for us.
What makes the signal different?
I mean,
I'm,
and this is a compensation you Scott and I had originally in,
which was,
you know,
what's going to be the distinction between Duke Thomas,
let's say,
and a a Dick Grayson or,
uh,
Kate who's bat woman.
And I think there's a opportunity with Duke since he is,
um,
we can say a potential metahuman we'll just say potential at the moment,
but since he has these burgeoning powers,
it's,
it's kind of the first time Batman has a chance to kind of get in early on the
ground floor on a new hero.
So I think Duke,
um,
and I think to kind of go back here,
I think,
I think because of the loss of so many Robbins,
um,
I think,
you know,
Batman has an opportunity to do it differently this time and maybe,
maybe discovers he doesn't,
he needs the robins that he already has,
hopefully intact.
But you know,
Duke Thomas is a what the heck?
If they aren't,
I mean,
you can only have what,
five or 10 disposable Robbins at a time.
I'm not sure.
Um,
but I think do Thomas is,
is an opportunity and the seagull in particular,
it's for Batman to,
to operate in a different kind of mentorship role.
You know,
if it's almost like,
um,
if,
you know,
Batman had had met a superman,
I'm sorry.
Now I feel like I'm in middle school.
Like if Batman and Superman,
this is what I don't like.
I know,
but,
um,
but it's,
it's almost like the ground floor element of maybe even preventing,
you know,
um,
of another future rogues gallery from,
from emerging,
right.
Another set of many humans who will destroy Gotham.
If,
if he can mentor Duke in way under his particular philosophy,
perhaps,
you know,
we'll see a different gospel.
Here's hoping
the robins that don't die keep turning out to be very evil.
So
absolutely.
Go Jason side,
Jerry,
go fine.
Um,
in,
in terms of the,
you mentioned that the darkness,
that Batman's ultimately happy.
Um,
it is,
it sort of brings into question though,
this opposite 75 years of Batman is also 75 years of the joker is and saw on
your,
your book just dropped yesterday,
um,
the white nights.
So we see a not only rehabilitated joker,
but a,
a sane and heroic aspiring heroic joker.
Yeah.
And potentially a more insane or perceived in St.
Like if you took away the insanity,
then he can be a true genius,
a true a machiavellian enemy.
And he be even worse because his,
uh,
his craziness,
there's imbalances handicapped him.
If he took that away and now he's just like a smooth don draper who he's,
he talks,
he gets his record expunged,
he shows that the cops just fudge,
saw all the paperwork and my version of Gotham joker,
it's never proven that he ever did anything super bad.
Um,
it's a big attic.
That cotton candy was really nasty.
Um,
but yeah,
I've always,
that's,
that's kind of where I went with mine.
It's like,
how do you do anything new with the joker anymore?
I know a few operators have tackled a cure joker before,
but I really wanted to see it done,
uh,
to,
to really follow that all the way down the road.
You know?
So there's,
you're saying that within,
if frank is,
if I'm hearing is,
um,
within Batman's brooding,
vigilante violence is an actual,
um,
uh,
a happiness and a hopefulness,
and you're saying that within the
really psychotic,
um,
yeah,
there's a sane man saying,
is this just a sane man?
But,
uh,
yeah.
Uh,
very in control and respectable,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
even somebody,
yeah.
Even though we'd all love to toss the joker out of Gotham,
as soon as the security starts creating these amazing arguments about why Batman
is causing the problem.
And you know,
we know a lot about sociology now white crime exists and we know that punching
back doesn't make sense.
You know,
like in the forties,
that comic mostly made sense.
But we know now that that doesn't work.
So what would Gotham be and if it was right,
I guess,
who should retire the police department altogether?
It's a great question that's asked you three as,
as we've come to know more sociologically psychologically,
what challenge does that create for you as writers?
You've been hitting that to me,
you're mistaking whatever the current trend in,
in,
in thought is for knowing more.
Sometimes people are wrong for millennia,
but you know,
during Spanish inquisition they thought they were doing the right thing.
So this is that your take,
is that Batman?
We,
we keep,
we can't stay the course.
He stays,
he,
he will throwing fists.
Oh,
I know.
I was just talking,
I was just talking to response to what he said.
But no,
in terms of,
in terms of what Batman is his,
he's,
he's just a wonderful,
very versatile myth.
It could be anything.
It can be anything from death wish to Robin Hood.
Mm.
Yeah.
Well.
Well wait,
what you're saying is the interesting part is that yeah,
he's,
he's uh,
people ask,
you know,
it could Batman beat,
do better for the world and be less guilt if he just was a billionaire and turn
it all into charity and,
and,
and help.
I mean,
he probably could save more people,
um,
as a scientists discovering cures than you could ever save punching.
Well,
two things about that.
One is he wouldn't
do that because,
because,
because he's,
he's,
it was a myth.
We can do it way wrong with them.
That would make for one rotten comics,
it's a second one that really clicked.
Men fixes the just the educational system.
I don't think I'd want to draw that.
They tried that during the late seventies.
Oh yeah.
They called it social relevance.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So,
well,
if all of all the things he could be,
there are certain things that he has to be,
he has to be the world's greatest detective.
Yeah.
How hard is it to be anything more than that?
He's got to be the smartest guy in the room under new circumstances.
But that means that you all have to be the smartest people in the room,
especially in this room,
swam.
Um,
but it really,
is there a challenge in,
it's like you've,
you've,
it's gotta be foolproof.
It's got to be the world's greatest detective level story all the time.
No,
because you're,
you're,
you are the smartest person,
but you're also the stupidest person in the room.
You're everybody in the room.
Your,
your unity,
your,
the collective consciousness of his entire economy.
Oh,
so he's a,
he's a rich and broad enough characters,
so control,
perform different functions.
Um,
he's also part terrorist in that day strike terror into the hearts of criminals.
You know,
he,
uh,
his first night out in dark knight is a rampage of terror to,
to,
to make all the criminal scared.
Um,
and it continues it to the series in any day.
Now he does,
he dresses up like a giant bat.
This guy isn't around a reassuring.
Yeah.
What would you say for each of you is,
what is your fingerprint on the character?
And though it is the thing he say,
like I gave Batman that
I gave them a really high color.
I have his Batmobile to exhausted on the front,
so it's always shooting flames.
And I made a Arkham look like Castlevania attract Transylvania castle.
So Batman's become like the devil in the city.
I sort of a storytelling element.
So I,
I mean,
cause I draw,
people can actually see the hard work I do
surrounded by artists.
I'm in trouble here.
Oh wait,
no thanks for,
I'm with frank on this too.
I forgot.
Yeah,
I forgot that you got the frame.
We and your husband
forgot.
We have some books we can get.
I add to that.
The only,
the Batmans been around for 78 years.
He's been written in every medium.
Um,
a guy named Frank Miller wrote the best Batman story ever and I,
you can't write better than that.
Did he draw that to
the collars were really low and see what,
like shorty or so second smartest guy in the room.
Um,
so the only thing you can,
it,
I just,
I,
you can't add new ideas to them.
And what you can add is yourself,
you put yourself into Batman.
Um,
cause it's the only thing original you can bring is sort of your own
consciousness and experience or whatever.
Um,
yeah.
So what would I add?
It's a bad,
but I don't know.
He's a little more emo.
He stares out windows and sadly,
um,
uh,
I,
I think,
I think I added to Batman or what I'm trying to add to Batman is his happiness
and,
and him trying to be happy,
which,
I mean,
I can't make Batman darker than you made him and I can't make him a more of a
family man.
And you made him James or uh,
as high collar does,
you made him.
Um,
but I can make,
that's the one place that I think we can go with Batman that'll create a lot of
conflict,
is giving him a little happiness and seeing how that mixes with his bitter.
Hmm.
All right.
What about you?
What did you do as your fingerprint?
I'm working on it.
A book's not out yet,
but a little bit more a sunlight since I'm dealing with a daytime Gotham.
Yeah.
I'm giving,
I'm giving him a little bit more Bruce.
A little bit more.
Bruce Wayne,
a little bit more a r and r during the daytime,
maybe about 15 minutes.
Yeah.
All right.
James Packer.
Okay.
Well,
I,
uh,
Frederick Wortham when he wrote seduction of the innocent and proved to comic
books where we're the source of all juvenile crime.
Um,
he claimed that,
that,
that um,
Batman and Robin had the perfect homosexual relationship.
I Made Robin a girl,
so they are well done.
Well,
I,
um,
I mean in detect,
honestly I don't feel like I have put my fingerprint on Batman himself.
I've been focused much more on his relationship with,
uh,
with,
with each existing characters,
ones that have been playing into the mythos for,
uh,
like the,
throughout its history.
And,
uh,
I've tried to sort of sort of hit a iconic moments between him and each of the
characters that sum up,
sum up their dynamics in each of those ways.
And I've been trying to create a Bruce that rather than immediate,
uh,
Bruce that says yes to like,
cause it so many times.
There are these store like when they would introduce a new,
uh,
a new character coming up in a new young vigilante and Gotham,
there are so many stories of Batman just saying no like Batman,
just like trying to shut them down out the gate.
And this is the Batman who I think is more like the idea that Batman's a loner
when Robin showed up like one year in like if just a few years into the creation
of Batman,
like Batman has been about family for the whole time.
So the idea of him,
how do I make this work?
How do I bring these people in?
How do I create,
uh,
something,
something bigger and can it work?
Is that,
is that end?
Is it actually a good thing to actually say yes to all of these young people at
the same time who are trying to work out their issues by bring them all in?
Yeah,
but like 30 Robbins.
Yeah.
I mean that's basically a detective.
We got a major bank robbery with machine guns being used 10 me,
10 Robbins over there.
I'm too busy over here.
Yeah.
You know,
one is bound to get through.
Yeah.
Basically taking the approach of the 300 and just applying it here to Robin's.
Yeah,
I like it.
Fodder.
Sorry.
100 naked.
Robin's
there we go.
It would sell.
If you've got it,
there's a market for everything.
You're talking about putting yourself into the character,
your,
um,
your background is in the CIA.
How does that,
how has that influenced,
uh,
your,
your creation?
Uh,
I mean it,
it influences everything I write.
I just,
I mean that's how I spent my twenties.
If I was to write about my current life,
I just be writing about a guy who writes Batman and grant Morrison already did
that.
So,
uh,
so,
so yeah.
So it,
that,
that sort of experience of,
you know,
having seen people really be brave and having seen people really be afraid and
having been both of those two people,
I,
I can't talk about directly cause it's all I'll get arrested.
Yeah.
We get that.
And a,
I mean,
I care,
I don't want to leave the secrets,
but also the arresting is big.
Um,
so I put the emotions in it and,
and,
and I sort of draw from that experience.
I mean,
my standard line is like,
it helps,
um,
writing about getting shot at if you've been shot at.
But I think that's kind of BS.
I'll probably just say that it doesn't help at all.
Does sound cool?
Yeah.
Cause if I wrote it stinks because you can't write realistic,
like Batman's famous thing.
Frank,
you do this better than anyone is to date when he's interrogating someone as a
dangle them off a building and then,
you know,
open his hands up and be like,
ah,
and then they just start confessing.
That doesn't actually work.
MMM.
The time I do
hurt.
So
you don't steal a realism too much.
Um,
you all hold on,
hold on.
Are we going on the roof right now?
No,
no,
no.
Not at all.
No.
It's just,
he just said the dreaded word realism.
We're talking about a guy who dresses up like a bat and drives in a car that's
30,
30 feet long,
puts a child in danger every time he goes out into action.
And we're talking about realism,
think,
give,
you gotta go,
you gotta lean on,
you have to lean away from the realism that you can't lean so far away that it
breaks.
Right,
right.
Absolutely.
Right.
But that's,
it brings up an interesting point because you do bring realism frank into your
work into dark night.
Um,
has these constant,
very real political themes and through all three installments from Reaganism to
nationalism,
run a muck media,
dark knight master race as the last one is particularly poignant right now.
So do you come from a political perspective when you're writing these stories or
is that just what happens to fall in?
Yeah,
we've,
I mean,
obviously there's a political perspective in,
you know,
in life if you're,
if you're,
if you're awake and,
but I'm also,
when I started the very first dark knight,
I,
uh,
it just struck me as odd that comics were so divorced from,
from everything else in the world and that,
and that,
uh,
here we have all this cartooning talent.
We're not using it to do what cartoonists are most known for,
which is political cartoons.
And,
and,
uh,
so to me it was just a natural marriage and I also gave the series of Greek
chorus that is a way for the rest of the world to react to Batman being out
there.
Um,
and that's just been a device that's continued throughout.
One thing we mentioned backstage and this was,
um,
every installment of the dark knight returns as now happen during a Republican
administration.
Coincidence,
just that's when the story came to you fail.
I don't know.
It's diplomatic and answer as we could hope and all is
direct.
It's just,
you know,
I've got no idea dude.
The,
the,
uh,
I mean you'd think they'd,
I don't know.
All right.
Let me pal
something.
I want to come back,
Tony,
to something you said earlier about you're bringing Batman a little more into
the light and doing this and you said that,
you know,
Scott them by day.
Um,
Gotham itself is as much a character in the myth os as any as,
as Robin or the joker.
And more so then any other setting,
uh,
certainly more than metropolis.
Um,
how,
how has that influenced you?
Have you played with that?
How do you guys think of that as a character?
It's a big,
it's a big sandbox to play in,
um,
especially daytime Gotham because
even now it's were working on it.
It's,
we're figuring out what,
what the,
the,
the distinction between nighttime Gotham,
which is what mostly we've seen in,
in the majority of the books and then a new day time ecosystem.
So is that where,
you know,
new heroes and new and new villains actually test out there,
skill sets plans.
Is this where,
uh,
I,
you know,
I actually,
I imagined that daytime Gotham is a little bit more corrupt than nighttime.
God.
And if we start looking at,
one of the things that we're investigating is kind of the,
the,
the systems,
uh,
that run during daytime.
Uh,
also if we talk,
if we get into,
not to say that we are getting into politics in Goffman,
but I mean this is when,
you know,
a lot of these corrupt politicians in Gotham or are working during the daytime.
So,
I mean,
there's a lot of different opportunities.
I feel that that got them by date,
gives us,
um,
does he have like a special costume that he wears somebody.
Okay.
He allowed his usual camouflage.
Well,
signal does,
so signal has,
um,
is,
uh,
the signal is,
you know,
so he's,
uh,
to,
to give you guys,
if you don't know who took Thomas's over the last,
uh,
about five years,
he's gone from a,
just a,
a teenage kid who helped Batman out in the jam to being part of a,
an autonomous group of Robin's.
They lived most of them,
frankly.
Um,
how many Robbins?
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
Sorry.
Would you like to talk about to know,
because I,
so it was a few years ago and I mean,
and this is what got me invested in do Thomas,
is I was at New York comicon and I walked by a table and I saw black Robin on a
tee shirt and I was like,
it's African American Robin,
man,
it's a narrows,
rotting off.
And so,
um,
but I saw the t shirt and I was like,
I gotta get this.
Yeah.
Like,
and so then,
and I knew nothing about Duke Thomas at that point.
So then I went back and we had a red,
uh,
we are Robin and,
you know,
filled in the gaps in.
So here I am,
man.
We'd be sitting here actually using him in my book.
Which one?
Duke.
Thomas woop.
And I look,
I used to Thomas and so I have him as like,
as,
uh,
um,
some marvel character.
A guy.
Miles Morales.
Sure.
Sorry.
Oh,
the Netflix show.
What's it called?
What's his name?
Luke Harris.
Dare Devil.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I'm looking out here.
Uh,
smartest guy in the room.
We don't know what marvel characters.
Luke cage guy.
He's defending his neighborhood.
It's like he's in Bedstuy or like a rough neighborhood where Batman or the
police don't go.
So he's just sort of taking matters into his own hands.
So that's sort of what I'm,
when I'm working with,
I don't know how that fits.
I mean,
well,
so much else world.
It's not
even Canada.
It's not even,
okay.
So elsewhere.
It's no,
someone said else world,
Eh,
they still know they should.
They don't stamp it like that.
Oh else old.
Yeah,
they,
they beat up else worlds in reacting to dark night cause they wanted to say this
didn't happen
then he works so much of it into cannon.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So that's kind of an I'm following in your footsteps here.
I was like,
let me just tick off them,
mess with it.
I'm going to just tear it up and whatever you guys like at the end,
you can just use that just like the way you did with dark knight yet.
And they thought like,
okay.
They were convinced like,
well it worked with frank.
Maybe this,
this kid can do something like that too.
I don't know.
Not that I would ever expect to fill your shoes,
but I had you as an example to throw in there facing the idea.
Right.
Do it now.
The idea is each,
each guy had bat kicks.
Things kicks the bounds as far out as possible.
The next guy can can do it.
I'm kicking it really hard and filling anybody's shoes will,
in terms of diversity,
you've created a bat team that is like,
not just largely,
it's a majority of women?
Well,
I mean there's a lot of great like,
I mean right now we've like bat woman,
the bat woman that Greg Rucka created with,
uh,
or developed with a judge Williams was one of the,
I think the best additions to the mythos and uh,
a long time and the,
but that character had kind of existed standalone.
Uh,
she had not really interacted with the bat family itself and,
uh,
there were,
had been little mentions before that they are,
that there is a familial relationship.
So it was like bringing in,
uh,
Batwoman as a,
as a kind of mirror to Bruce as his cousin,
as someone who,
uh,
you know,
comes with a more military background and how,
how the two of them play off of each other.
It became sort of core to the team.
Um,
but honestly,
in building the team,
and a lot of it was just me like asking to use my favorite characters and them
saying yes.
So this begs the question,
how much freedom do you have on this iconic character?
Can you do,
how do you decide like,
all right,
he's going to be married now,
which that that is now you start doing it and you see when they say none the
best that the best bet is to come in when,
when,
when the sales are really low.
That's,
that's,
that's what it does when you get to help me pitch products here.
Um,
yeah,
the being sales low is really helpful.
That's why I tried crash every project and then raise it back up.
Uh,
I mean I got daredevil when it was,
they was,
they were just getting set to cancel it.
So I got to do anything I want it to.
Oh,
the best thing happen in common cause you get of nobody cares about it all it
all around the block.
Yeah.
That's the best.
Um,
but I mean the,
the company in the editors want a story that will capture the public.
They don't want you to be a cover band.
They don't want you to just be like,
okay,
here's the hits.
They won't play them over and over again
sometimes.
But sometimes you know,
they,
they don't,
if you get a good editor,
if they don't,
that's where you got to find the right editor.
Yeah,
that's,
that's 100% of the shoe I bought any,
it's one of those things where I think maybe in the safe,
the safe options,
what they want,
cause you know,
that's the easiest way not to get fired,
but in their heart and their dreams,
they want to do something radical.
They want to be the editor of dark knight returns.
They want to be the publisher who publishes the next thing.
And if you can trick them into thinking you're doing that,
then you're cool.
All right.
Uh,
so that's the whole thing if you,
if to push a story for it.
But you have to,
I mean the whole point of working with the Batman character is there is a
quarter of that character.
There is a core and you can't,
and you're responsible to the,
to the fans.
You're responsible to the people who came before you not to destroy that core.
And if you do,
then your story loses its stakes.
If I'm writing a Batman that doesn't mold to that point of that,
and then I'm just writing sort of bad fan fiction,
um,
and having written some bad fan fiction and my left in that ready to go back to
it yet.
So,
so,
um,
so as long as you stick to that core,
you can move that character forward.
And it's a,
it's amazing.
I'll well conceived the,
the,
the best characters are that,
that there's,
there's not much you can really wreck about Batman that is,
unless you just,
unless you just completely trashed it,
you know,
and,
and betrayed it.
He's like Superman.
He's just,
he's such,
such a good idea or wonder woman.
They're all such good ideas that does so much better than superman.
What are you talking about?
Superman is a boring care.
He's superman is the one I want to do next.
Okay.
No,
but don't,
you're lucky if the sales are low.
I don't know if that's true.
Actually.
That's true.
Okay.
Superman is not boring characters.
Just go read some of the stuff that and Schuster did.
Yeah.
But means nevermind.
Bizarros
you don't like to,
like the more wising are going crazy about,
but to me,
Bam in is,
is talking about this stuff where he could push planets around.
No,
that's not real interesting.
You know,
once he got more powerful than God,
he stopped being a really interesting character.
But,
but uh,
but the,
but he was,
he,
but he started out as a character with a,
I'm using,
he was in great idea that begat all the rest of them.
This is the problem to me.
It's the motivational problem.
You,
you,
you do a Spiderman.
Oh my,
I left.
The guy killed my uncle.
He's like,
that is that guilt for the rest of his life.
And you can always go,
we did Batman.
My parents died.
Like there's just a fundamental flaw.
Superman is just,
that's not there.
It's not,
there's no,
that's simple explanation of why he does what he does.
He's,
he's a mentally healthy hero.
Yeah.
I can't,
at least for a little while,
longer
superman.
Mentally healthy.
All right.
So geeking out a little bit.
Frank,
your daredevil
versus your Batman who would win Batman.
Yeah,
no radar.
No white.
Just he beat up superman.
All right.
Tom,
you were Batman versus your mister miracle.
Well,
Mister miracle is not as superhero.
All he does is escape from things.
It's,
it's fairly useless in a fight unless you want to escape from the fight.
What do he escape from the fire?
Yeah.
Banner would have trouble holding him.
But I think beyond that in the who would,
when Batman is always the,
when where,
who does he lose?
He the only person he loses against this as writers.
Right.
That's why we have the power or his heart.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
it's like the only person Batman loses against his Batman.
Like that's the,
that's really the only only way to do it because he,
he represents like this core idea of overcoming things like,
oh,
over co coming the worst thing.
So no matter what the worst thing is you throw at them to make it a Batman
story.
He overcomes it.
Yeah.
My,
my first draft
of,
of the first dark knight ended up with him dying in a hail of police gun fire.
Um,
and I did,
but it did not become a useful end it because,
no,
I just didn't,
it didn't,
it didn't work the magically or emotionally or anything else.
It wouldn't have been good ending.
So what challenges does that create for you?
Is,
I mean,
when you know going in,
this is the character that is undefeatable that only Batman can be Batman.
How do you keep that fresh?
Oh,
I think the bank could die.
Sure.
It's just the,
just the,
the,
the uh,
um,
but no,
keeping it fresh.
Well that's,
that's why they have to keep replaying soon as I guess,
you know,
now it's just too much good stuff to do with them.
I mean I think that the,
for me it was always trying to find his greatest weakness.
And for me its greatest weakness is that extended family we're talking about.
So I think each writer probably has the challenge of figuring out,
you know,
what is your interpretation of his biggest flaw
one ended.
And these characters are,
these characters that have been around for so long are subject to each writers
interpretation,
each cartoonists interpretation too.
Cause they,
they look different,
they and they feel different and they read different.
Um,
and,
and uh,
that keeps them going more than anything.
It's just,
I,
I can't imagine,
you know,
people just sticking to one,
one heroin for 40 years
before we are annual to audience questions one more.
Um,
well Sean and frank,
you draw the works that you're writing.
Does the story influence your art?
Do you find that it changes and for the rest of you,
does the artist you're working with change how you tell a story?
In my case I'd say yes,
yes,
yes and yes.
Um,
the,
uh,
I adapt my art style to the story I want to do.
Um,
and,
and uh,
you know,
with,
with uh,
switching from Sin City to 300 for instance,
was a switch to a much more linear style because it's going to be a color book,
but also big.
Also because color was such an important factor in the story.
The Red Capes were a big part of the story and the Persian enemies,
the,
the Persians were,
you know,
notoriously wealthy and flamboyant and in their costumes and such.
So it's,
it's you,
you have to adapt to each project you're working on or it becomes boring for
you.
And therefore the audience.
I think the secret weapon for me is if I'm writing and drawing my own stuff.
Like these guys are a level writers,
a lot of the things that they talk about,
I haven't even thought about that yet.
I'm kind of,
I can,
he's faking.
I can kind of crank together a plot,
but I only do one a year.
I have to draw it.
And if there's any holes I can just try to draw my way out of them,
you know?
So by,
cause a lot of times when I worked with a different writer is always meets
communications and uh,
it does add up.
Hopefully most readers don't notice it.
But when you're drawing your own,
like you know exactly what the dialogue is,
exactly why that facial expression works and that clean connection is something,
as much as I love working with Scott,
it's never going to be 100%.
So my failures as a writer,
I think I can make up for them by my connection to myself being the artist.
There's stuff I've done in pages where you know Batman's,
the lights are out as an ENP.
The hits got them some doing all these crazy things with the art.
Scott doesn't know how to write that panel because you need to visualize it
first and work backwards like frank can do that.
Cause you know he knows that his artist who was,
who was himself knows how to do that.
But most writers just generally don't think like moment to moment storytelling
or using an illustration that turns into sequential panels.
Like it's tough.
Like you need to talk to your artists to make sure it'll work,
but when you're the same guy all and one,
you can do that stuff more and more effortlessly.
[inaudible]
so there.
All right.
We have questions from many of them.
Mike,
set up.
All right.
Thanks so much for coming today.
Thanks for having me.
This is a question I,
and I've had it.
I've had a lot of art forms,
but I think it's particularly pertinent to you or is it the that Dan,
uh,
when you sit down to write something new,
do something that has such a long cannon,
do you ever have an idea and say to yourself,
well,
I want to check and see if anyone else has done that before or are you not
deterred by the concept of someone else having tried something and you just want
to make it your own and give it your shot at if you ever walked away from ideas
because they weren't necessarily brand new.
Yeah.
Did I use this program on this?
This is called Google and
miss dope.
It's 100% sure.
I'll have an idea and I'll be like,
this has been done.
Your check is ready.
I will literally,
I will literally use Google just to suck up a little bit.
Uh,
I use Google every day,
uh,
to,
to check ideas and to look at the past history.
Cause a second check is ready.
This is Google.
We can do a five checks.
Is there anything else nice you'd like to say about Google?
We don't like to just simply mention its name,
about five.
He's told me like Google the crap.
I also,
I have two nerds that are my friends.
They run a podcast called comic Geek speak.
Uh,
um,
that was a plug for my buddies.
That's actually not the name of it.
It's called Gotham by today anyways,
for Geeks anyways.
And I use them as a,
as a brain trust and they just their beer nerds than I am,
which is saying something because they use Google.
No,
they used Yahoo.
Their
guts
are my head up.
So yes,
that's a long nerdy suck up question to answer.
I use Google a lot to
me.
Three got the checks.
All right.
Sorry.
I've got a
like a full bookshelf of pretty much like every major Batman story that like I,
that meant something to me going up,
uh,
growing up and uh,
I spend a lot of time revisiting those stories.
A lot of it is,
uh,
is to make sure that I'm not retouch it,
like touching on beats,
uh,
from before.
But it's a lot also me finding the moments that moved me the most in try not to,
not to recreate them,
but to get into that,
that mindset of where I was when I was reading it and how to express what I'm
feeling now.
I think Tom said earlier that it's about putting yourself into it and that's the
thing that's never been,
uh,
been in the comic before.
It's,
it's my perspective.
My Batman is different than everyone else's Batman are because they're,
the stories that matter the most to me.
It's a different constellation are than any of the other writers up here.
Uh,
so that,
like that Batman,
how that Batman reacts in this scenario.
Like yeah,
there might be a story,
uh,
from 20 years ago that might touch on some of the same themes and obviously I
don't want to,
I want to be aware of that.
And I don't want to like,
just,
I don't want to make it boring for the reader.
Uh,
but bringing,
like if I,
if I feel like I'm saying something,
uh,
with the story I'm trying to tell and I'm bringing these characters in and we
using like my Batman,
my,
like the,
the version of Batman that I hear in my head when I,
when I write like that,
that is different.
Um,
so I,
I don't,
I don't concern myself too much with it,
but I like,
I am conscious of it.
Yeah.
Sort of a followup on that to the rest of the people I said,
it sounds like you've kind of grew up in Batman was always three of your
favorite part of the comic universe.
Uh,
but for everyone else,
is that the same for you?
Like you were always,
that was your favorite growing up and you're most drawn to it or were you more
just sort of drawn to comics generally?
Any sort of ended up doing Batman stuff?
I was big on super boy and the Legion of superheroes when I was a kid.
A great character.
Batman came a lot later,
like the Jim shooter Britain by a 13 year old.
Yeah.
It turns out that I ended up working for that guy.
For me,
it was Batman in the X.
Men.
Like those were the stories that I just gravitated to over and over and over
again,
which is why I'm writing the x men starring the bat family right now.
So I even just,
I stole the danger room because marvel is not using it.
So
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
I started with a
x men first and then I was lucky enough to read and this is not,
uh,
Frank's not going to send me a check.
So then I read dark knight returns and that kind of was a game changer for me.
Um,
and then watch men also.
And uh,
and then since then I've just wanted to write comics milestone,
a lot of the milestones stuff as well.
And um,
so here I am,
I've came from watching a lot of Batman,
the animated series.
All right.
Yeah,
yeah.
And yeah,
I feel very,
I did stuff I don't know about comics is scary.
I don't know how I got this bar.
I usually check with Scott or her or you or anybody who will listen and I think
I have this great idea and Scott will say,
yeah,
that's a great idea.
I did it last year.
I'm about to do that.
Or I did it years and years ago,
so I just stopped talking about to do that.
That's a horrible answer.
That exact idea is mine.
I'm about to do that.
Great idea.
Yeah.
But then my friend's like,
no,
you can't get into comics without reading the milestone stuff.
So that's when they gave me dark knight and watchman and you know,
some called Baker stuff.
Um,
you know,
a lot of indie stuff too.
You know that since it,
he wanted to all of them,
obviously I'll take that check.
Clean Black and white comics don't give checks.
Do you know when you're writing?
Well,
as opposed to when you were,
are the things you're like,
man,
this is really rolling for me.
This is on the,
this has problems
or times when I'm sure it's really good.
Um,
and they may be terrible or maybe really good.
There are times when I think this isn't really a good when it's certainly not
good
for me when Scott Snyder heals my ideas.
[inaudible] you made it.
All right.
Thanks guys.
You guys all great.
Thank you.
We have one more quick question we can do.
All right.
Awesome.
Hey guys,
former DC ensuring here.
So thank you.
Let's do meets it.
Thank.
Thank you man.
We got to get to here.
Awesome.
Uh,
so it seems like,
you know,
over the last decade or so Batman has become Bruce's like fulltime identity or
job.
I'd love to hear how you guys approach writing like the Batman Persona and
writing the Bruce Wayne Persona and how you balanced that.
I mean,
isn't Bruce Wayne actually the mask?
I mean that's,
that's one interpretation.
Maybe it might,
my feeling was always stepped when when Batman retired,
Bruce Wayne started dying and Bruce Wayne actually started steadily getting
younger and healthier when he,
when he put the cow back on.
So he,
he doesn't feel comfortable and straight cloths.
I don't think
there's a,
like I forget who described this first,
it may have been mark Waid,
but there's a night like an idea that for both,
uh,
like Batman and superman that had,
cause there's a lot of talk of dual identities,
but that there's actually a kind of,
it's actually a three part system that there is,
there's Batman or the,
the persona he puts onto frightened criminals in the street.
And there's Bruce Wayne,
the persona he puts on to mask the fact that he's Batman.
And then there is the strange man in the cave.
There's this figure in the cave who was speaking to Alfred who is still
connected to that eight year old boy who is still that eight year old boy,
uh,
that he was before.
But he,
he's driven to be this thing and he's driven to eat.
He's,
he's never going to really be able to grow up because he,
he will always be in that moment.
Uh,
and that when he,
when he succumbs fully one way or the other,
uh,
it doesn't quite work.
He so it's like he needs to stay in touch with that person in the cave,
which is why I think that his relationship with Alfred is so powerful.
Why is relationship with the Robbins is so powerful?
Because they actually know that person and there are very few people who do.
What about baton might,
where does he fit in?
He's just as big as fan.
Don't you find it kind of spooky about how we now casually referred to that?
The robins?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
how many Robbins can do what you added and Robin,
you're not innocent,
but I didn't kill her.
Well,
that's what we have time for.
Thank you very much.
This has been amazing.